my life
hasn't been what you probably think it
has
we all have our struggles have you ever
been in love
a long long time ago
you so many times yeah all the time
think about finally having everything
you always wanted
i can save today but you can save the
world
now i take what i want in return
everyone will see
[Music]
i will need you
you know you need to do
[Music]
nothing good is born from lies
and greatness is not what you think
it's uh that just is trash can it's just
a trash can
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is gonna be my wonder woman 1984 trailer
breakdown in easter eggs there's a whole
bunch of stuff going on in this they
told us what's going on with the villain
maxwell lord
in cheetah so we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the easter egg
videos we'll do a new dc merch giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the trailer on the video
make all the mandalorian pedro pascal
baby yoda jokes that you want about this
we'll just start at the beginning of the
trailer and work our way through shot by
shot
the trailer picks up in 1984 she's been
continuing to save the world save
everyone around her do as much as she
can
but she's super lonely as you can see
because most of her friends from world
war one have died off
there's a whole bunch of pictures and
easter eggs in the background like you
look at the little mantle here there's a
picture of
trevor manor something that she coined
in the name of steve trevor
they actually go back to steve trevor's
watch a couple times remember he gave it
to her before he died so she carried it
with her but
they start with it at the beginning of
the trailer then before he appears to
her again
in full members only 80s attire with his
giant fanny pack
they go back to the watch but it's only
after you get the maxwell
lord intro so if you're familiar with
the classic version of maxwell lord that
they introduced in and around the
justice league international period in
the comics
they're doing something a little bit
different with the character you find
out that she's pretty friendly with
cheetah before she becomes cheetah this
is the barbara minerva version of the
character
the reason why they said they went with
kristen wiig for this role is because
they needed someone who could do
funny and personable like this like
she's kind of an awkward funny person
talking to her about being lonely have
you ever been in love she says oh a long
time ago referencing steve trevor
she says she's been in love a bunch of
times so it's just this funny nice
conversation that they're having over
drinks
and they needed someone who could do
that and then also go to the full
crazy town full-blown cheetah makeup and
they did say that her costume would be a
combination of practical and special
effects
so when she goes full cheetah they did
have to use a little bit of visual
effects to tune her up
you may have also noticed an easter egg
in the way that they did the titles for
the movie in the warner brothers logo
they're inspired by the classic
christopher reeves superman titles with
the way that they fly at the screen
now these are just dialed up to the
maximum 80s level with a bunch of neon
thrown in
but part of the reason for setting the
movie in 1984 is it's meant to be the
maximum period of our current
ideology maximum greed maximum egos
and what kind of villains would come out
of that and that's where you get the
maxwell lord villain in this movie
the song playing in the trailer is blue
monday classic 80s track
are you going to the mall today
obviously malls were huge in the 80s
they said most of stranger things season
inside a giant mall so of course there's
going to be a maul during this
if you were at comic con in hall h you
probably saw some of this footage way
before everyone else
it's not clear why she has to destroy
the mall security cameras when she's
saving these people but two people just
try to shoot it up so she takes them
down
it's also meant to give you a preview
for the crazy practical way that they
did their action scenes they said that
very little of this is actual special
effects they try to do as much of it
real
world as they could you get your first
preview for maxwell lord the way patty
jenkins explains him in the movie is
that he's the king of infomercials
so he's trying to sell everyone on their
fantasies so because he's a super
powerful telepath in the comics and he
has this
giant radar array wherever he broadcasts
his signal from
you can imagine that there's probably
some of his comic book telepathy
involved in what he's trying to sell
people on
this specific shot of him with all these
infomercials is also meant to be an
easter egg for this classic 80s ad
his speech about everyone getting
everything that they want fulfilling
their fantasies having the better life
that they want is also meant to be a
parody of ronald reagan's famous
shining city on the hill speech during
the 80s because it's 1984
reagan would be president at this time
if you don't remember the shining city
on a hill speech it was a big speech
that he gave to the american public to
pump them up
because we were coming off this really
bad recession the economy was terrible
and he was basically coming out and
saying no
everybody could have their dreams
there's this bright future ahead for us
trying to get them to forget about all
the terrible things that have been
happening for the past couple of years
so maxwell lord is sort of the darkest
timeline parody of that
you also notice how they've tuned the
color on her way up i mean the whole
movie is
super saturated but her costume pops way
more than i've seen it in any of the
other movies that she's been in
gal gadot also claims that this movie is
bigger than any movie she's done before
which includes the justice league movie
you get another quick shot of barbara
minerva thinking about things that she
wants
obviously it's not totally clear how she
becomes cheetah and how close that's
going to be to her comic book origin
but in the comics she became cheetah
when she was cursed by a village of
people she's an archaeologist in the
comics she's an archaeologist during
this
do you see maxwell lorde holding this
artifact i'm assuming that she has
something to do with getting him that
artifact
love the way they introduce steve trevor
at this party though he walks up and
puts the watch in her hand
just like he did before he died back
during world war one
it doesn't seem like she questions it
that much she just completely embraces
him like oh i'm so happy that you're
back
the rest of the trailer is a little
misleading in the way that they cut it
you're just meant to assume that he's
really
back but because of maxwell lord's
powers and how he's trying to sell
everyone on this
fake life i also kind of feel like
there's some fakery going on with steve
trevor in the movie
like maybe it is fake mind space steve
trevor and it's just maxwell lord's
power that he's broadcasting this signal
trying to make everyone feel like
they're getting the things that they
want when really it's not happening
what's not totally clear is maxwell
lore's powers in the movie does he start
out with powers or is it this artifact
that gives him powers to make everything
feel like it's that much more real
this is just another big disaster that's
happening near the capitol building in
the street you see her wearing civilian
clothes that look a lot like linda
carter's clothes during the 70s wonder
woman series there's a rumor that she'll
have a cameo somewhere in this movie but
i didn't spot her anywhere in the
trailer
for some reason the white house security
guards are firing at her and steve
trevor it's not clear why if that has
something to do with maxwell lord
or he makes the security guards believe
that wonder woman is trying to kill the
president
great slo-mo shot they just want to show
you her abilities it's been a while
since we've seen her on screen so
they're just trying to show off how
fantastic their action scenes are and
how much more they've evolved the way
that they use her in scenes
they really upgraded the way she uses
that lasso but i think that they've just
used the last couple of movies to
perfect
what they can do with the lasso
practically like how do you make the
lasso look cool in action scenes
i will get to the lassoing lightning
part in a second because yes i do
think that there is an invisible jet
that we just don't see because it's
invisible
during the trailer this kind of seems
like it's barbara minerva
after she starts to transform into the
cheetah persona like she gets what it is
that she wants or she pays that price
the first movie was wonder woman just
being completely amazed by modern day
london now it's steve trevor just
completely being blown away by
everything in present day 1984
you see her intervening in an
international incident this wall being
torn down i think is meant to be a
reference to the berlin wall being torn
down but that was until 1989 so this
isn't the berlin wall or anything like
that this is somewhere completely
different
i think it's just meant to give you a
sense in the movie for what she's doing
internationally she's busy helping
people all over the world
i know there are a lot of timeline
questions because they said in batman v
superman
they implied that she hadn't been around
for the last 40 or so years
most of those timeline inconsistency
questions can be answered by the idea
that they retconned her backstory in
batman v superman when they got to the
first wonder woman movie
so when this movie picks up in 1984
she's been busy being wonder woman
since world war 1 ended here's the weird
thing about mine space steve trevor
though he actually punches
one of these guards so either it's
wonder woman imagining him doing that or
it really is happening
but it's not clear if this has something
to do with the artifact that maxwell
lord has like maybe he is getting people
to conjure these things up for
themselves because of his telepathic
powers
but maybe the artifact has something to
do with making those things real
turning fake things into real things you
have to remember that the 80s was a very
fake it till you make it kind of decade
you get a lot of flashbacks to themskera
you see them cut her running down the
street in washington dc
trying to save people with her as little
girl running in formation with the other
amazons
but here's why i think that there's an
invisible jet in the movie because she
lassos something in the middle of the
air that's not there like literally the
lasso grabs onto something and lifts her
off the ground
and there's nothing there so what else
could that be but the invisible jed
but because maxwell lord has that giant
transmitter satellite i'm assuming that
this device is connected to that somehow
and he's using it to broadcast his
telepathic signal to get everybody to
just believe everything that they want
to believe
this big action scene on the road seems
like it's happening in the same foreign
country where this wall is being torn
down
also just another big action scene meant
to show you how crazy they can get with
her action scenes
there's a nighttime action scene with
her going up against this giant armament
then you have a much bigger version of
her seeming like she's lassoing the
lightning bolts
so like i said if there is invisible jet
during this maybe there is an invisible
jet somewhere in this
scene that we're just not seeing the
golden armor looks fantastic
if you guys aren't big comic book
readers this is just meant to be a
version of her gold armor from the
comics it's just meant to be
a much more war-like version of the
costume she wears obviously the wings
are just meant to represent some of the
excess of the 80s so it sort of
dovetails with the theme of the movie
the heightened state of everything so
that's why her armor levels are over 9
and the reason why she would need to
wear something like this covering her
arms and her legs
is when cheetah goes full cheetah
because when she gets her powers
cheetah is strong enough to take wonder
woman down and her claws are strong
enough to just
rip right through her flesh so that's
why wonder woman would need to protect
her open exposed areas
then because there's a lot of humor in
wonder woman movies they end up that
funny tag with steve trevor not being
able to tell the difference between
modern trash bins
in art that's also meant to be a joke
about art during the 80s is it art or is
it just a piece of trash
who knows but if you spotted any big
easter eggs in the trailer that i didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments
crisis on infinite earth's episode 1
starts tonight
my next video will be for episode 1 so
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should get all those
videos
but click here for that brand new crisis
on infinite earth trailer and click here
for my mandalorian episode 5 video for
more pedro pascal
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you